you know i come you know i'm a russian
jew
and it's always interesting i take pride
in um
and you know i love the
of the soviet union of russia i love
america so i love these countries they
have a beautiful tradition and in
literature and science and art and all
these kinds of things
but it's funny that people
not often but sometimes
correct me that i'm not russian
i'm a jew
and it's uh it's a it's a nice reminder
yes
that um that is always there that desire
to create these groups and then when
they're living in the same place
for that
division between groups that hate
between groups can explode
and i just i wonder
why is that there why does why does the
human heart
tend so easily towards this kind of hate
you know that's a big question
in and of itself
you know the human heart is full of
everything right it's full of hate it's
full of love it's full of indifference
it's full of
apathy it's full of energy so yeah i
mean hate is something you know that um
i mean i i think er er and you know
along with hate you know the ability to
really hurt and injure people is
something that's within all of us you
know it's within all of us and it's just
something that's part of who we are um
and part of our society
so you know we're shaped by our society
and our society can do with us often
what it wishes
you know that's why it's so much nicer
to live in a
more or less beneficent society like
that of a democracy in the west
than to live in the soviet union
right i mean because um
you know you have more or less the
freedom to do
to do what you wish and and not to be
forced into situations in which you
would have to then do
nasty to other people
um now some societies as we talked about
you know or more
are more have have proclivities towards
you know asking of its people
to do things they don't want to do and
uh
and forcing them to do so so um you know
freedom is a wonderful thing
to be able to choose not to do evil is a
great thing you know whereas in some
societies
you know you feel in some ways
for not so much for the nkvd bosses but
for the guys on the ground you know in
the 1930s or not so much for the
nazi bosses but for the guys you know
and the police
battalion
that we're told go shoot those jews
you know and you do it
not necessarily because they force you
to do it
but because your social
you know your social situation
um uh
you know encourages you to and you don't
have the courage not to
yeah i was just uh as i often do
rereading viktor frankl's man's search
for meaning and he said something um
i just
i often pull out sort of lines
the mere knowledge that a man was either
a camp guard or prisoner tells us almost
nothing
human kindness can be found in all
groups even those
which as a whole it would be easy to
condemn
so that's speaking to
you feel for those
people at the lowest level implementing
the orders
of those above right
and also you worry yourself what will
happen
if you were given those same orders you
know i mean
what would you do you know what kind of
reaction would you have
in this similar situation and
you know you don't know
i could see myself in world war ii while
fighting for
almost any country
that i was born in
there's a love of community there's a
love of country that's just um
at least to me it comes naturally just
love of community and countries wanting
such community yeah and i could see
fighting for that country
especially when you're sold the story
that you're fighting evil and i'm sure
every single country was sold that story
effectively
and then uh when you're in the military
you have a gun in your hand or you're in
the police force
and you're ordered
go to this place
and uh commit violence
it's hard to know what you would do
it's a mix of fear it's a mix of um
maybe you convince yourself you know
what can one person really do
and over time it's again that slippery
slope
because you could see all the people who
protest who revolt
they're ineffective
so like if you actually want to
practically help somehow you're going to
convince yourself that you can't one
person can't possibly help right
and then you have a family so you want
to make sure you know you want to
protect your family you tell all these
stories and over time
it uh you naturally convinced yourself
to dehumanize the other
yeah i think about this a lot
mostly because i worry that i would be a
good german yeah no no that's right
that's right and one of the
you know one of my tasks as a as a
teacher right
are students
and i have you know classes on genocide
i have one now
and another one by the way on stalin
um but the one on on genocide you know
one of my tasks is to try to
try to get get the students to
understand this is not about weird
people who live far away and in time and
in place
but it's about them you know and that
you know that's a hard lesson
but it's an important one you know that
that this is in all of us you know it's
in all of us and there's nothing you
know
and you just try to gird yourself up you
know to try to figure out ways that
maybe you won't be complicit
um and that you learned how to stand by
your principles but it's very hard it's
extremely difficult and you can't
the other interesting thing about it is
not predictable
because they've done a lot of studies of
poles for example who during the war
saved jews you know well who are the
poles who save jews versus those who
turn them in
it's completely unpredictable you know
sometimes it's the worst anti-semites
who protect them because they don't
believe they should be killed
right
um and sometimes you know you it's not
predictable it's not as if the humanists
among us
you know are the ones who uh you know
can consistently show up you know uh
you know and and experience danger in
other words and are ready to take on
danger
uh to defend you know your fellow human
beings not necessarily i mean sometimes
simple people do it and sometimes they
do it for really
simple reasons and sometimes people you
would expect to do it don't
you know and you've got that mix and
it's just not predictable
one thing i've learned in this age of
social media is it feels like the people
with integrity and the ones who would do
the right thing are the quiet ones
in terms of humanists in terms of
activists there's so many points to be
gained
um of declaring that you would do the
right thing
it's uh it's the simple
quiet folks
um because i've seen quite
on a small obviously much smaller scale
just shows of integrity and character
when they were sacrificed to be made and
it was done quietly
now this sort of the small heroes um
those are um you're right they're it's
surprising but they're often quiet
that's why i'm distrustful of people who
kind of proclaim that they would do the
right thing
right
right and they're different kinds of
integrity too i mean
i edited a
memoir of a polish
uh
you know underground fighter uh member
of the underground who was in majdanek
in the concentration camp at majdanek
you know when he was just an interesting
mix of different kinds of integrity
you know on the one hand
you know he he it it really bothered him
deeply
when jews were killed they're sent to
the campers that sort of thing on the
other hand he was something of an
anti-semite
you know um he would uh
you know sometimes
if jews were his friends he would help
them and if they weren't sometimes he
was really mean to them
you know and you could in their various
levels you know a concentration camp is
a
you know a terrible
social experiment in some ways right uh
but you learn a lot from how people
behave and what you see is that you know
people behave sometimes extraordinarily
well in some situations and
extraordinary poorly in others and that
it's mixed and you can't predict it and
it's hard to
hard to find consistency i mean that's
the other thing it's you know
i think we claim too much consistency
for the people we study and the people
we think about in the past you know
they're not consistent any more than you
we are consistent right
you